good to see you this morning thanks very
much for coming in let's talk about the
earthquake and the aid response first of
all if we can because today marks of
course one week on from this devastating
couple of earthquakes to strike turkey
and Syria it took four days for aid from
the UN to get into Syria do you agree
with the UN Aid Chief when he said that
the International Community has failed
Syria Luke I think there's always more
we want to do in these situations in the
UK we've sent out just under 80
Personnel to help out Specialists search
and rescue personnel and with the
government's matching five million
pounds of donations from the public but
there's always one more we want to do I
think the truth is though the very
difficult situation with countries like
Syria where you've got
um people who are hostile to the UK
they're on the ground and we're doing
what we can to help people hundreds of
aftershocks as well following those two
major first waves of earthquakes and I
think all of our out to the people there
who's you know especially those who are
you know still searching for families
buried under collapsed buildings across
Eastern Turkey and of course we have
sanctions against Syria at the moment
the U.S as it's looking to ease some of
those sanctions if it helps get Aid in
and to the people that need it will the
UK do that I think we'll be looking at
everything we can when it comes to
humanitarian circumstances we always
want to do what we can to help on the
ground I think that's a sensible thing
to do we don't want to have anything
which could go in and prolong more
suffering for people as well though and
you know we have been out there on the
ground doing what we can to help out
with specialist teams because we have
some of these specialist teams you'll
listen all the way back from 2001 when
we sent specialist teams to help out in
America as well and tragically so many
of their First Responders uh died and
and that's a really good resource that
we have and we're fortunate not to have
those issues here in the UK but no
decision on sanctions no I think we you
know all the government will be looking
at all these things in the round
um but I'm sure it you know we'll be
working lockstep with uh important NATO
Partners like the US on matters like
that I want to turn to to the issue of
spy balloons because the defense
secretary Ben Wallace is saying today
that Britain's going to conduct a
Security review
um after the incursion of these apparent
spy balloons over parts of North America
How concerned is the government I think
the government is is concerned about
what's going on we're concerned about
influence more broadly of some states I
mean one of the things that I think
people don't think about when they think
of China is uh is is is some of these
real issues which are which are there
we've taken hundreds of thousands of
people uh well 140 000 people from Hong
Kong into the UK last year alone because
of the persecution they're facing we
look at the uyghur population who are
being uh you know who are being treated
absolutely appallingly in parts of China
as well the slave labor conditions too
that China is a hostile State and we we
need to be aware of the that and the way
it acts and behaves I think there was a
there was an error when China could have
gone a different way and perhaps opened
up but it's quite clear at the moment
it's not going in that direction and
we've got to be really robust in our
dealings with China is it possible that
Chinese fire balloons have already been
used over the UK I mean it's possible
you know it's also possible that and I
would think likely that there will be
people from the Chinese government
trying to act as a hostile State we saw
with Russia here in the UK with the
Salisbury poisonings and other actions
that they've taken I think we've got to
be realistic about the threat that these
countries opposed to the UK they're not
interested in our Democratic Values
they're not interested in standing up
for human rights around the world we are
and you know we've got to keep promoting
those values
um at the same time as whenever we can
offer Sanctuary to people from some of
these countries especially we've got a
relation to with reference to Hong Kong
in that context should we be increasing
defense spending the defense secretary
is pushing for an increase in the
defense budget do you back him on that
we've already increased the defense
budget very substantially you know I saw
Ben speaking about this last year where
we're seeing an extra I think it's
around 24 billion pounds over the next
uh 10 years going into defense where the
largest contributors to Nato in Europe
um that's all good and obviously you'll
have seen from the last few weeks the
huge amount that we've been leading the
watch a few few weeks almost a year now
you know uh in in the response to
Ukraine with the extra resources we put
in there there's always more I'd like to
do but it's got to be done in the
context of a balanced section of public
finances I want to see as always have a
strong defense and that's also got to
we've also got to have a growing economy
which is which is what pays for all
those public services and also we've got
to have those other public services
which constituents need on the ground as
well let's talk a little bit about
strikes now because the RCN the nursing
Union is talking about escalation of its
strike action their warnings that staff
from a e from intensive care from cancer
Awards as well could be involved in the
next round of strikes also exemptions
for some hospitals May no longer be
granted what's your message to patients
who are waiting for life-saving
treatment and can you say honestly that
the government is doing everything it
possibly can to stop these strikes well
from the transport side we've just had
that you know sad news from yesterday
the rmt aren't you know I I'm going to
ballot their members on a new offer what
I want to see is a settlement there I
think we've been pretty open with a lot
of the unions about that we've got union
members as well as as well as the
representatives employers on these pay
review panels you know we ensured that
last year the well everybody else in the
public sector was facing a pay freeze um
nurses got a an average of three percent
rise and so you know we do recognize
that there's a special case for nurses
and I think some of the way that they've
behaved during the pandemic as well
letting people know to ensure that
Services remain open is really important
to what I want to see as a settlement
here as quickly as possible but the most
important thing we can do not just for
nurses
um but for everybody whether in the
public or private sector is get
inflation down because that will eat
away any pay rise people are seeing at
the moment that's why the government's
committed to halving inflation by the
end of the year because it's a tax on
everybody and whether you're working in
the public sector whether you're a you
know a somebody who's retired whether
you're in the private sector and that's
that's got to be our top priority or we
don't want to do anything to keep
fueling that inflation because that will
just make the situation worse and we'll
always be chasing our tail okay so
that's got to be the concentration okay
well nurses might say we can't wait for
inflation to come down so too like rail
workers as you say the rmt have rejected
what was described as the best and final
offer from from train companies you as
you say you're a transport minister so
where does that leave talks will you be
going back around the negotiating table
well as I said about inflation you know
we've got a Target to Harvard by the end
of the year so we're not sure we're not
asking people to wait forever we're
really pushing on this as a top priority
but to come to the transport unions the
rmt have been offered a backdated pay
rise of five percent for last year
compounded with a four percent rise for
this year and all of that pay will be
paid and backdated and that I think is a
pretty generous offer around uh just
over nine percent for the average rail
worker and higher for those on the
lowest incomes as well I think that's a
good deal we've the government have
really tried hard here my colleagues
Hugh merryman uh has you know and Mark
Harper have worked really hard you know
facilitating these talks between the
network rail the train operating
companies and the unions the unions I
think they need to have the confidence
if they still are rejecting our offer to
go to their membership and say that
that's what they want and they want a
fresh ballot they've not done that and
they won't ask their members for their
views the truth is I think a lot of
people who working in the rail industry
now would like to see this settlement
happen they'd like to see the pay rises
in their pay packets you know that would
be a big boost for a lot of those lower
page Railway workers and I think that's
what I want to see and I think the uni
needs are the confidence to go to its
own members and ask their view quick
thoughts on what labor is highlighting
today they're highlighting uh government
spending on credit cards government
issued credit cards today they say
there's a pattern of using these cards
for lavish entertainment luxury hotel
stays is there a culture of lavish
spending in government departments at
the moment when people are worried about
paying their bills certainly not I mean
when I was on my last visit I was up in
Lancashire last week to Berry I stayed
in the a very well appointed Premier Inn
and drove myself up there with some of
the team as well in order to save on
costs and get there in good time all
we've seen is over the last uh 12 years
we've seen a reduction in the 2009
almost 1000 1000 million pounds was
spent on these cards we're seeing that
down to around 150 million pounds last
year that's an 85 reduction plus the
labor says there's a 70 increases well I
mean you'll have to ask Angela Reyna
when she's on with you but 2009
995 million pounds spent on these cards
last year by their own figures uh under
around 150 million there's a big
difference there and what I want us to
see is as government spending uh all
properly declared transparently
obviously there'll be some situations
where you know if people are traveling
internationally and there's a big
International Conference there will be
as you know more expenditure on certain
things
um but what we saw in 2012 was all of
this is all of these figures are fully
available on the government website I
checked it out myself and there's a
monthly transparency reporting of this
and transparency is the best thing
sunlight is a great disinfection for
this sort of stuff and so I think that's
why it's so important that we're as
transparent as possible with what the
government spends in word will you ban
these cards I know well I think there's
a use for them and actually if
everything had to be invoiced you know
you can't actually do stuff that you
need to do and can be more expensive and
more bureaucracy what I don't think we
should do is introduce more bureaucracy
as sort of gym hacker style Department
of administrative Affairs to
administrate the other administrators
which seems to be Labor's proposal I
don't want to see more bureaucrats I
want to see transparency coming through
and helping us keep government spending
as reasonable as possible for taxpayers
in my constituency across the country
okay Richard Holden thanks very much for
coming in today